[Música]
imagine selecionado para assistir uma
aula sobre o tema que você sempre quis
aprender o professor dessa aula é o
melhor
conhecedor do assunto no mundo essa aula
tem 60 minutos e vai ser sua única
chance de aprender sobre esse tema mas
logo no início da aula
você percebe que está ansioso demais e
ainda fica preocupado com a prova que
virá em seguida o professor começa a
aula mas a sua ansiedade é maior que sua
atenção e concentração a aula termina e
você sente que não conseguiu absorver
tudo o que podia e não está pronto para
a prova que virá em seguida
agora imagine que você voltou no tempo e
tem a chance de assistir novamente essa
mesma aula mas dessa vez quando o
professor entra ele percebe sociedade e
decidi que durante os primeiros minutos
da aula você fará um exercício de
meditação utilizando uma técnica simples
de observação da inspiração você irá
acalmar somente e aumentar sua
concentração
sendo assim durante alguns minutos você
faz respirações profundas e ritmados
sentado na sua própria carteira com a
coluna ereta e os braços relaxados
quando a nova aula inicia
você logo percebe que absorve tudo muito
mais facilmente e nem dá atenção a
fatores externos como a conversa das ao
lado
estamos aqui propondo uma técnica
simples com resultados garantidos que
toma pouco tempo sem custo pode ser
praticada em qualquer lugar sentada em
pé ou até mesmo caminhando uma técnica
que poderia ser praticada até mesmo em
sala de aula correto é comprovado
científicamente que a minha estação
promove o autoconhecimento e o
autocontrole emocional nas
mais variadas situações ela pode ajudar
os alunos a conseguir notas melhores nas
provas o que é ótimo ou até mesmo
ajudá-los a estudar a matéria toda em um
menor tempo
ao contrário do que muitas pessoas
pensam meditar não é não pensar em nada
pois é impossível a atividade cerebral é
constante o que fazemos na estação é
direcionar os ou retirarmos a nossa
atenção a determinados pensamentos
encontrará também do que você pode estar
pensando a meditação não está vinculada
a nenhuma religião apesar de muitas
religiões se beneficiarem de técnicas
legislativas daqui a alguns anos
a meditação com certeza será disciplina
obrigatória nas escolas
aliás muitas são as que já introduziram
a técnica que já traz benefícios para
crianças pequenas bem como para
estudantes em faculdades renomadas como
oxford e cambridge a questão exemplos de
algumas escolas que já introduziram a
meditação
muitas escolas ao redor do mundo já se
beneficiam da meditação em poucas
semanas percebe se o aumento de
concentração e atenção dos alunos
além da diminuição de conflitos o
professor se beneficia também pois tem
uma classe mais atenta e participativa
ea escola em se obtém melhores
resultados
a meditação também pode ser considerada
arma secreta de muitos atletas olímpicos
e profissionais que se destacam em seu
meio através da prática regular essas
pessoas controlam suas mentes
pensamentos e emoções
empresas como google apple ford e nike e
já entrou duzir a meditação na sua
rotina diária pois é um absurdo traz
melhores resultados na eficiência
e bem estar de seus funcionários
o tenista roger federer fala que a
visualização como forma de meditação
mudou completamente sua carreira sua
confiança e precisão aumentaram quando
ele começou a estar regularmente e
visualizar suas histórias
antecipadamente um dos melhores tenistas
do mundo de o clube fica tem sido
meditador por anos dando exemplos de
como a prática ajuda ele diz eu uso uma
estação para me recompor sempre que
cometeu um erro ela me ajuda a ter foco
e acalmar minha mente
aqui estão exemplos de outros grandes
atletas que também meditam para alcançar
seus objetivos
o jogador de futebol cristiano ronaldo
eo jogador de basquete michael jordan
celebridades como gisele 21 escritor e
giva larari utiliza uma meditação para
alcançarem sucesso e clareza mental e
todas as áreas da vida
por fim sabemos que a grande busca do
ser humano é pela felicidade e ao mesmo
tempo que a meditação é um dos melhores
artifícios para alcançarmos esse
objetivo
por que não começamos a usá la logo no
início da vida das pessoas nas escolas
já que o ideal é introduzir a meditação
o quanto antes que tal agora mesmo aqui
mesmo
fazemos um exercício de meditação afinal
como eu disse anteriormente ela pode ser
praticada em qualquer lugar estão
prontos vamos lá
mantenha a coluna ereta e os braços
relaxados com as palmas das mãos
voltadas para cima
fechem os olhos e tenciono em com força
as mãos e os braços e os ombros tenham e
agora relaxei
vamos repetir o nen mantenho relaxei
mais uma vez o nem tenham relaxem
mantenham os olhos fechados e as
pálpebras relaxada se inspirem
profundamente pelo nariz
[Música]
brendo do ar por alguns segundos
solte o ar pelo nariz ou mais devagar
possível
inspire profundamente pelo nariz
prenda o ar por alguns segundos
solte o ar pelo nariz mais devagar por
si tudo bem
se vier algum pensamento na sua mente
do mesmo jeito que ele vem ele vai
inspire profundamente pelo nariz
aprendendo a voar por alguns segundos o
softwall ar pelo nariz ainda mais
devagar você se inspire profundamente
pelo nariz
[Música]
brendo ano por alguns segundos e solte o
ar pelo ar e jo mais devagar possível
inspirem profundamente pelo nariz
prendeu um ar por alguns segundos e só
tem um ar pelo nariz ou mais devagar
possível
inspire profundamente pelo nariz prender
um ar por alguns segundos e só tenho ar
pelo nariz
ae advogar possível muito bem continuem
como os olhos fechados e podem voltar a
respirar normalmente
sinto uma calma que essa prática trouxe
pra vocês tentei manter esse sentimento
agora abra os olhos com calma de um
sorriso e parabéns vocês meditaram muito
obrigado por assistirem e participarem
dessa palestra e um ótimo dia para vocês
[Aplausos]